hi
i'm oriakashi and i'm a product manager
here at google working on the databases
team
joining me today are going to be doug
and shashank who are going to help me
explain
how cloud sql for sql server can be set
up and
provide value to yourself and your
organization
and all the familiar tools that today
you're probably using with sql server
on-prem
that you can also use with our cloud
offering we're going to kick it off
talking about an overview of the
different capabilities and features
that cloud sql for sql server provides
and some of the considerations you
should have
when setting up the service then i'm
going to focus in on some more complex
topics that we generally get a lot of
questions about
such as replicated persistent disk and
how that plays into our high
availability strategy
then we're going to hand it over to doug
and shashank we're going to share with
you a demo
about transactional replication and how
to set that up
finally it's going to come back to me
and we're going to talk about kind of
the next steps of where cloud sql for
sql server is going
and some considerations about
everybody's favorite topic licensing and
pricing
okay so if you're not familiar cloud sql
for sql server
is one of three database engines that we
offer as part of the cloud sql portfolio
it was released to general availability
early this year
and provides a fully managed solution
that will
provide common tasks and reduce overhead
such as
upgrades backups patching
and other key aspects to managing sql
server
today we have sql server 2017 four
editions that are available
such as enterprise web express and
standard
it's fully compatible with the tools
that you're familiar with like
sql server management studio and
powershell and we can automate a lot of
tasks via the apis and gcloud commands
as well as
the console ux you may be familiar with
just as you would with both postgres and
mysql as part of cloud sql
we show this map every year and every
year this just keeps growing in terms of
the number of zones and regions that are
available
and the key takeaway here is that cloud
sql
is available in all these regions and
sql server is
no different so you're able to have a
cloud sql for sql server in any of the
regions that
you are located in that gcp is expanding
to and
this map will just continue to fill out
as gcp continues its growth
so what you see here is actually the
cloud sql architecture that's common to
all of our database engines and i
thought i'd take a minute
just kind of diving a bit deeper so that
everyone can understand
what's actually going on under the hood
and so
on the left hand side what you can see
here is actually
each instance has their compute engine
vm
just like you would in gce that has a
cloud sql image
in a container with both sql server and
on all of our management agents
running on top of it this includes all
everything that we use for
monitoring management connectivity and
the like
powering that of course we have our
network layer which is common to
all google cloud products as well as
persistent disk for our storage layer
and so whenever we go and actually do a
deployment of sql server what we're
doing
is refreshing the the container on top
of the virtual machine
and then firing up kind of the
underlying storage layer
you'll see on in a few slides i'm going
to talk a little bit about how
persistent disk is actually used for our
replication solution for high
availability
and it's important to kind of tie that
back into the concept that you see
here so because we have the separation
of the virtual machine on the compute
engine
and this storage layer we're able to
more more easily move between
virtual machines and do things such as
live migrate
across regions or in different machine
types
change the characteristics or parameters
of the machines themselves
and increase storage as well without
incurring disruption
to your instance now on the right side
this is actually the control plane
that's powering all of cloud sql
and so we have our metadata servers that
provide us the management capabilities
to roll out
broad changes across the fleet and so
when we talk about things like
you know common interfaces or any kind
of new capabilities that we want to
provide to
all cloud sql customers not just sql
server customers
they're actually deployed on the control
plane themselves
such that they can be accessed by all
instances
so talking about kind of what that
deployment looks like and what that
creation looks like
from the customer perspective i wanted
to take a minute talking about
provisioning a sql server instance in
cloud sql
and so you'll notice if you've gone
through this flow
that we have the same machine types
that you're able to do again for
postgres or mysql
but if you're familiar with sql server
you'll know that it can take advantage
of the full breadth and capability of
the resources that we allocate to that
machine type which today
is up to 96 virtual cpu cores
624 gigs of ram and a 30 terabyte
ssd one key difference here is that
sql server in cloud sql only runs on ssd
you don't have an hdd option we found
that there's
increased resiliency and less issues by
only providing that one option
now you can initiate the creation of
this machine or a modification of
an existing instance again via the
console ux
g-cloud commands or our api much as you
would
for any other cloud sql instance again
you know
the most important thing here when
you're going and creating that instance
to make it useful is you want to seat it
with your data and so there's a number
of different options here
one of which we're going to talk about a
little bit later to actually use
transactional replication to set up
cloud sql as a subscriber and have that
kind of active
replication to bring in the data with
minimal disruption and minimal downtime
but of course you can always import into
cloud sql as well and so you can import
dot back native files and be able to see
your data
that way as well offline now
i mentioned it before but once your
cloud sql instance is in operation you
have a number of different other
options and parameters that you can set
one of which that we've
we've always gotten you know a lot of
good feedback from customers
is about the ability to auto grow your
storage and so
you don't have to pre-provision all of
the storage that you need
from the from the get-go once you do
that import
let's say you're importing a 500 gig sql
server instance so a number of databases
that way
you can set auto grow on the disk and
then
not worry about making sure you have the
correct allocation for projected growth
you know three
six you know nine months down the road
additionally you can set a number of
different options just as you would with
sql server on-prem so if you're familiar
with the command
using the you know stored procedure for
sp configure you'll know that you can
set a lot of those same settings
in our console and via our apis with the
the different options that we allow
under flags
that includes collation which is now
available as well
for high availability you know uh we'll
talk a little bit of a focus about how
that actually works but it's important
to note that in order to
really get the the most out of cloud sql
and
really take advantage of our three and a
half nine sla
you'll have to select a regional
availability configuration
and then make sure that you pay special
attention to maintenance windows and
kind of the appropriate time
for us to make any changes cloud sql
will of course
do its best to minimize any disruption
have maintenance events
you know happen as quickly and as
infrequently as makes sense
but our first priority is of course
always making sure that
the service is both secure and highly
available
the final point i wanted to touch on was
the automatic backups
we get a lot of questions around how
frequent you know customers can
take backups of their instance for dr
purposes or if they want to
then you know store them and you know
restore them into
other instances either on other clouds
or back to on-prem
if they're running a hybrid
configuration so
by default you'll have automatic backups
on a daily basis
that you can set a window when you want
them to actually occur
these are storage snapshots so they're
actually snapshots of persistent disk
and should not incur a performance hit
onto sql server itself because you're
not using the database engine
to take the backup in this case for more
frequent backups
you could of course set to you know
automate a set of
manual backups and use the apis or use g
cloud commands depending how you how you
want to interact with it
but then you need to manage the
retention of those backups
yourself so with the automatic backups
you have a seven day sliding window
with manual backups we don't actually
cap it we won't drop any backup
instances
uh it's more of a manual retention
management experience
but you when you log into the instance
you'll actually see a list of all of the
backups that you've taken manual and
you'll be able to
manage them from there as well of course
you can always export the data
we allow you know a full back export as
well
and you can leverage that in conjunction
of course but that does
leverage the sql server engine database
engine in that case
next topic i wanted to touch briefly on
was analytics
folks that are familiar with sql server
are generally interested in also using
the auxiliary services such as sql
server reporting studio analytics studio
and integration
services all together with sql server
and the best practice that we found is
actually running
those services separately in google
compute
engine from there it's very simple to
connect to your cloud sql sql server
instance
via you know vpc and actually have a
reliable
and durable pipeline that you can create
for any data analytics
or transformations that you want to do
native tools will continue to work as
expected so if you're using
things like query optimizer or you're
using you know any other
microsoft products you're more than
welcome to continue to use to use those
and just connect to that cloud sql
instance and it should behave as
expected
now if you want to use a slightly
different stack of course
google cloud has a very robust analytics
ecosystem
and so you can use tools such as data
flow or cloud data fusion
and just use a standard jdbc connection
string to go and collect connect to the
cloud sql
uh for sql server instance and
the specific database you're working
with and then set up
a data pipeline in that manner and
there's a number of examples that we
have those in documentation
and in that manner you can you know
bring that data
into other destinations for example
bigquery if that's something that you're
interested and familiar with using for
and those integrations will continue to
kind of deepen and become a robust over
time
i'll talk a little bit more about that
at the end
the third topic that i wanted to touch
on which is again something that you
know near and dear to all of our hearts
um and better better to talk about this
proactively than reactively if something
if something happens
um is security of course so google cloud
prides itself
on being a leader in the security space
and
there's actually a number of kind of
cloud-wide
platform features and capabilities that
we take advantage of in cloud sql
both to ensure consistency around all of
google cloud services
and also because it is kind of a
best-in-class solution
that we want to take advantage of as
well so google cloud if you're not
familiar encrypts both
data and transit and data at rest and so
at cloud sql we use that in lieu of tde
just to ensure that we don't have that
double encryption that could cause a
performance hit
as a result of this though we're also
able to take advantage of
customer managed encryption keys if
you're familiar with that functionality
as part of our key management store
and so just as you would set that up for
any other google cloud service
you can keep using that for cloud sql
it'll work
just the same in terms of connectivity
you have three options and really i've
ranked them here in order of
recommendation for
for security purposes so number one is
private ip
if you're connecting to other resources
in google cloud
this is actually the easiest and most
secure way to
connect and access your cloud sql
instance in your sql server database
um you know you can set that as part of
your vpc or peer
to vpc networks if you so choose uh
there's numerous step-by-step guides and
quick starts
and in terms of how to to get this done
and you'll get the best and then
simplest
experience that way of course this isn't
always possible especially if you're
coming from a different environment or
connecting from another cloud
and so for those cases you may choose to
use a public ip
and of course that brings a new surface
area
of security risks and exposure and so we
provide the cloud sql proxy that i've
linked to here
i definitely recommend using the proxy
in conjunction with
public ip whenever possible because it
will manage your
your ssl uh connectivity and and
settings as well
uh and it's also not going to require
you to
you know authorize any networks which is
another attack vector that we've seen
you know increases exposure to your
cloud to your cloud sql instance
finally if you do want to take on the
manual task of managing all of those
aspects
you're more than welcome to use public
ip those are available you'll get an ip
ipv4 address that you can go and connect
to
and you can connect from from anywhere
in the world as long as you add your
authorized network as well
the final point here is in terms of the
login credentials
so today if you use sql authentication
with
sql server for it as part of cloud sql
we actually provide you a
pre-cooked user which is sql server a
bit different if you're familiar with
using sa or sysadmin in sql server
and it is a subset of those permissions
we do this because
we want to ensure the integrity and
security of the service
and so you'll see you know we have a
list of functionality that's available
on our documentation site in terms of
what can and cannot be done
by the sql server user but the the most
important thing to
to know is some of the besides what's
not allowed some of the t-sql commands
such as the grant command
do have to use explicit syntax for
actually you know
granting as customer roles that we we
define
and so i definitely encourage you to get
familiar with
kind of the syntax and the capabilities
of this user
as part of our documentation before you
just dive right in but by and large
you'll see most of the commands that
you're familiar with
should just work
so as i alluded to before i'm just going
to take a quick minute here talking
about replicated persistent disk and how
that feeds into high availability
so you know this picture on the on the
on the side
here kind of serves the best purpose in
terms of showing you the flow of what
actually occurs
and so when in our high availability
you know it's a regional solution so you
have these two zones in the same region
the zones are of course separated as all
of our zones are
and you have your your primary instance
here in zone a
now that primary instance is that
compute instance i was talking about
before
and that's joined to the persistent disk
instance which is located in the same
zone
now those all are connected
to that persistent disk instance i
should say is connected and replicating
to the zone b persistent disk instance
and they're
always kept uh you know in sync by
this agent and so whenever you're
writing to one instance before that
write
you know the right to disk actually
succeeds it writes to both
persistent disk instances now
in front of all this we have our you
know ip address and load balancer
that's actually governing kind of
connectivity to to the instance so in
the case where one of our agents
notices that there's you know heartbeat
failure the you know the primary
instance is
unavailable what will actually occur is
that we will spin down that instance and
then switch over
into that secondary zone where we've
been writing to persistent disney's
entire time
we'll spin up a new vm a new container
of sql server essentially
and join that to an amount that per
second persistent disk to it
and reassign that ip address so from an
external perspective
there should be minimal disruption and
actually no connectivity change because
you'll be using that same ip address
same connectivity path
a couple important notes here this is
not using sql server's native
capabilities and so it's edition
agnostic you can do this with web
edition if you so choose or even express
and have an aha configuration which is
sometimes helpful
to keep your you know development
environments or if you want to really
right size and go
lean uh with your sql server instances
you're more than welcome to and still
have aha capabilities with our sla
backing it
finally i just wanted to mention uh that
you know typical times that we'll see
here
you know we don't want too many false
positives so the heartbeat connection
can take up to 60 seconds for us to
actually determine it's a true failure
or true unavailable
you know event at that point we'll
initiate the switch over
generally speaking you know
optimistically you'll you'll see it
under another
under another minute sometimes it could
take as much as you know a couple
minutes on top of that initial detection
so
just a few minutes later and you'll have
that failover experience
and finally i just wanted to call out
before we switch over into the demo
that sql agent is actually running on
all of your cloud sql for sql server
instances
and so you're able to create sql agent
jobs just as you normally
would moreover all of the sql agent logs
are written out to our operations stack
with stackdriver if you're familiar with
that
so you can set up monitoring and
triggering just as you would with your
on-prem solution
now let's go over to doug mayhew and
shashank to talk a little bit more about
how this is done in practice
hi i'm doug mayhew and with my colleague
shashank agarwal
we're going to show you how to migrate
an on-premises sql server instance to
cloud sql
this slide shows a typical scenario
where you have an on-premises instance
you have an application connected to it
and we want to migrate the data to cloud
sql without shutting down our
application
so to do that we're going to use sql
server's data replication
functionality as already mentioned
earlier sql agent is enabled by default
in cloud sql instances
and in the demo shashank is going to
show you how to do this with sql server
management studio
but you could use any tool that you're
used to for database administration and
sql server
cloud sql for sql server works with
powershell azure data studio whatever
you're accustomed to
um so you set up the distributor node to
coordinate the transactions moving data
from the publisher to the subscriber
in our example we'll use the publisher
instance as the distributor node as well
but in production scenario we'd
recommend that be a dedicated gc
instance in the middle once you kick off
the migration
snapshot replication happens first now
this could take
hours because this is moving your entire
database all the history and everything
over to cloud sql however your
application can continue running
because those transactions are being
stored and those transactions will be
replicated next and you'll have an
eventually consistent
cloud sql for sql server instance that
includes all of the transactions that
took place during the snapshot
replication
so this shows what's happening there
we're now migrating the individual
transactions over to sql server
in the cloud and the final step is to
just migrate your application over
change your connection string point it
to cloud sql for sql server
and now you're running in the cloud with
all of your data migrated and no
transactions lost
so now shashank is going to show you
step by step exactly how to do that
i have a source vm which is installed
with sql server database
in your scenario it can be an instance
outside gcp
this will be your source it will be
migrated into
instance of cloud sql
i have pre-created a sql server 2017
standard instance
so let's get on with the migration
let me rdp into this so as you can see
on this
screen i have already rdp into my
machine
and i have restored
adventureworks lte database which is one
of the sample database
provided in microsoft and i
am and i would be
using this database to replicate the
data into cloud sql instance and
i have connected to my cloud sql
instance as well
and you can see there is no databases
inside there
so first step uh to do this
is to set up distribution for
convenience purposes i am setting up
distribution on the same node
where the primary database lives
and this can be a different node as well
so once distribution has been enabled
i'll set up publication where i'm
telling sql server
to use transaction replication for my
adventure works lte database
and i'm then selecting what articles
will be replicated to the target so
essentially i'm selecting all the tables
you'll notice that
the build version table is disabled and
this is because it doesn't has a primary
column
which is a this is something to be aware
about that transaction replications that
not work with
non-primary key databases and next uh
it's asking me if i want to filter
anything i do not
i'm instructing it to create a snapshot
of the database to initialize the
subscriptions
and then i'm providing the credentials
for
[Music]
for this distributor to connect to
for this publisher to connect to the
distributor
since this gce vm is
has not joined any domain i am
essentially
supplying my windows credentials
for it to work
and then lastly i'll provide a
name of this publication
so once this publication gets created uh
we'll see
this in the list and
next next we'll add
this distributor as one of the owners of
the source database
so i have added distributor admin as one
of the owners
and now we'll create a subscription
so i'm giving it
sql server cloud sql instance as my
subscriber to this publication
right now i do not have any database in
this
so i am instructing it to create a new
database
and as as this would be done you would
see a new database generated on the
right
on the left hand side
and this would be a blank database at
the moment
but as soon as
this configuration is complete then it
will start replicating data
into this newly created target database
and once again i'm providing the
credentials
my source and target systems
sql server cloud sql sql server
offers connectivity using sql server
login
so let me finish this
once i will finish this it will
start replicating data and we can
click on this and view synchronization
status
to show what's going on so right now
it is saying it is dropping the agent
and if i would go into my target
database
i can see all already the table schemas
has been replicated
and if i would instruct it to select
some top rows
i am already observing that some top
rows
are already inserted into it
now let's see
how it is doing
so that would conclude our demo the
any further changes in the source
database will be automatically
replicated into the target
thanks shashank and now we're going to
go back to ori he's going to tell us a
little bit about
pricing licensing and what's coming next
for cloud sql for sql server
thanks so much doug and shashank it's
really great to see transaction
replication
live and see how to use cloud sql for
sql server
in practice so now i'm going to talk a
little bit about
everyone's favorite or least favorite
topic pricing and licensing
it's really important to kind of
demystify this and make it a bit more
transparent and that's something that we
always strive to do here at google
so breaking this down cloud sql for sql
server
is really made up of three components
when you talk about how we do price and
pricing so we've got our instance price
which
if you're familiar with cloud sql today
both for postgres and my sql
there should be no surprises here so
you've got that same
region specific price that's comprised
of core
and memory uh h a instances are going to
be
twice as much on the instance mainly
because we we maintain those two
instances to provide you that failover
so you have that standby secondary
and if you have watched any of the cloud
sql presentations
so far at next you'll know that we've
now released committed use discounts
and so those are now available as well
and so if you choose to prepay
you do get a discount both at the one
year and three year commitment levels
which can be fairly substantial it's
additionally important to note that that
commitment is actually
able to be used across all cloud sql
products and so
you can go and use kind of your your
committed amount
both for sql server and let's say for
postgres if you're interested in having
applications that leverage databases of
both types
now the unique part for sql server is of
course the licensing
you know as a partner reseller for
microsoft we do offer
uh you know the sql server license that
we have to as part of our cloud sql
offering
now the nuances here are very similar to
what you see in compute engine
and so the license cost is charged on a
per
vcpu basis there is a minimum of
four cores however and so even if you
run a smaller instance
you will have just the licensing
component actually be charged at four
cores and up
and this is of course varies by addition
with express actually having
no licensing cost in that case byol
unfortunately is not available for cloud
sql but it is available for compute
engine so if that is something that
you know is a requirement for your
organization i definitely encourage you
to go
speak to any of the folks over with
compute engine
or reach out to any account manager or
google support agent and they can guide
you through that process
the final component here is fairly
standard across
all google cloud products we have our
storage and networking price
uh the interesting parts here for cloud
sql are going to be how we charge
backups
um backups are charged a bit different
than capacity actually
at a cheaper rate um but you'll see that
kind of that same h a
fee difference is is baked in as well
and so
uh you'll have kind of capacity being
charged twice but backups not
now finally networking you'll have
ingress being free into your cloud sql
instance but i would definitely
encourage you to take a look at kind of
the egress pricing so there are no
surprises
because based on how you expect data and
traffic to leave your cloud sql instance
you may get charged more or less so it's
there's a bunch of tools online a bunch
of calculators and
guides that will help you navigate and
reduce any complexity there
so i want to talk just a brief moment
about what's coming next we're really
excited here
on the cloud sql team about what's
developing in the service
so if you're not familiar there's a
number of sessions out there talking
about the managed service from microsoft
active directory that we provide as part
of google cloud
you know we showed this last year at nx
in conjunction with cloud sql for sql
server and that's something that that
integration is actually coming
very very soon so definitely keep an eye
out for that
it'll be on of course all the the
typical blog posts and channel marketing
channels that we provide here
uh additionally there's going to be a
number of new high availability
high availability and dr options that
we're going to be
rolling out as well and so i definitely
encourage folks to
to keep an eye out for those in in the
coming period
migration improvements you've seen a
little bit about how you can manually
set up transactional replication but we
will be providing
a uh an additional more streamlined
functionality in conjunction with our
database migration
service that we've also recently rolled
out as well
and finally a deeper analytics
integration and so we talked a little
bit about how you can set this up
uh you know connecting to cloud sql with
dataflow and cloud data fusion
to get to bigquery we're definitely
focused around
investing in that workflow and how we
can kind of stream that
streamline that relationship so for
folks that are familiar with the
google analytics ecosystem you should
have a much easier time moving forward
using classical products like sql server
alongside those tools as well
thanks so much for joining us today and
talking a bit about cloud sql for sql
server
i definitely encourage you to check out
all the other great content here at next
uh if we're the first session you watch
thank you so much and and we're
flattered
uh but you know there's tons more to see
on the site so check out the catalog
here we've listed a number of sessions
related to
cloud sql now beyond that of course we
have
a number of sessions if you're more
interested on microsoft on gcp
in general so as i mentioned active
directory has a session
as well as compute engine so lots of
great content there
as well as our keynotes of course so
definitely take a moment browse the
catalog
find more interesting content and and
hear from more of our wonderful speakers
now we've also put together a showcase
demo for cloud sql i definitely
recommend
checking it out and you can go and
actually see in action
a bit more about how cloud sql operates
and some of you know
the the replication and the failover
occurs
and finally if you want to just dive in
and get more hands-on
we have quick labs up for cloud sql at
the link you see here as well
and so definitely recommend checking
that out trying it out and
seeing if you know you can navigate
through all of the steps
and start using cloud sql for sql server
and with that i just want to say a big
thank you from doug shashank and myself
as well as the entire cloud sql
engineering team and all the other
disciplines that we work with
it's a real pleasure to bring this
service to you and we really hope
that you find it useful and enjoy using
our service thanks so much